let's go he's on his feet already there
we go
last week an inquest found francis quinn
father hugh mullen noel phillips
joan connolly daniel teget
joseph murphy edward doherty
john laverty joseph core
and john mccur who were killed in valley
murphy
in 71 entirely innocent
on behalf of successive governments and
to put on the record in this house i
would like
to say sorry to their families for how
the investigations
were handled and for the pain they've
endured since their campaign began
almost five decades ago
no apology mr speaker can lessen their
lasting pain
i hope they may take some comfort in the
answers they have secured
and in knowing that this has renewed the
government's determination to ensure
in future that other families can find
answers with less distress
and delay mr speaker this morning i had
meetings with minister or colleagues and
others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings
later today mr speaker i
strongly associate myself with the
earlier part of the
comments that the prime minister made
can i raise something
slightly different though it's nearly
four years
since the grenfell tower tragedy claimed
some 72 lives
yet hundreds of thousands of families
still live
in unsafe unsellable homes and many
leaseholders face crippling debts
through no fault of their own trident
point
peer main house amber court all in my
constituency
given this was the biggest building
scandal in modern uk
history why did the prime minister order
his mps to vote down
our efforts yesterday to get this
scandal sorted
once and for all prime minister uh mr
speaker
i i i no way i underestimate the the the
the suffering of those who uh
the victims are grateful and also those
uh who's whose buildings
whose homes uh have been prejudiced by
uh the the spectra of unsafe
uh materials and that's why we provided
an unprecedented five billion
uh pounds of investment and i can tell
him also that
the most dangerous cladding is already
gone or is going
from all high-rise buildings and we
certainly agree
that leaseholders should be protected uh
from immediate from remediation
costs and people in high-rise buildings
will play will pay
nothing uh to replace their unsafe
cladding
uh mr speaker the prime minister will
understand that havering
just like hillingdon is located on the
outskirts of london
and has very different needs and
aspirations
from those in the core area of the city
my borough still prides itself
as part of essex and i know that his
does as part of historic middlesex
and whilst we need cooperation on things
like transport
will he accept that it is time for
wholesale reform
of the way london and the wider region
are governed
and support my campaign to allow
boroughs like havering
to take back control from the mayor
and city hall interference allowing
havering
and indeed all outer london boroughs the
freedom to make their own decisions
that best meet the needs of local people
well i i can understand the feelings of
of frustration uh that the people of
havering may feel about a
a current mayor of london uh who does
not understand the needs of out to
london
uh who has not uh invested united london
in the way that a previous mayor
did who i seem to recall set up the
outer london fund
and drove and drove through many other
benefits for the outer boroughs
but i must tell him in all canada that
what we need to do is work together
uh to ensure that that glad day returns
when we have a mayor who truly
represents all londoners mr speaker now
come to the leader of the opposition
thank you mr speaker can i welcome the
prime minister's comments on the bali
murphy
inquest and the sentiment uh behind them
does the prime minister agree that the
single biggest threat to hitting the
june 21st date for unlocking
is the risk of new variants coming into
the uk
prime minister mr speaker i certainly
think that that is
uh one of the uh issues that we must
face but perhaps it would be
for the benefit of the house if i update
uh the house on
uh where we are because we've looked at
the data again this morning
and i can i can tell them speaker that
we have increasing confidence that
vaccines are effective against uh all
variants including uh the indian variant
to his
uh to his point and i want particularly
uh in this context to
uh thank the people uh of uh of both the
blackburn many other places who've been
coming forward in record numbers mr
speaker
to get vaccinated to get their their
first jabs and their second jabs
uh mr speaker i think the numbers have
doubled in bolton alone
and i think the people this country can
be proud of their participation
mr speaker i think that's a yes that the
risk of other variants
coming through our borders is one of the
biggest threats to unlocking we're not
just talking about the indian variant
we're talking about future variants
in those circumstances why on monday did
the prime minister choose to weaken
travel restrictions by moving 170
countries or territories
to the amba list prime minister uh
mr speaker we have one of the strongest
border regimes anywhere in the
in the world uh there are there are
currently uh 43 countries on the
on the red list mr speaker but if you're
coming from an amber list country
everybody uh
should know uh that if you travel to an
ambulance country for
uh for any emergency or any uh extreme
any extreme reason that you
you have for doing so you when you come
back mr speaker
uh you not only have to pay for all the
the tests but you when you come back you
have to self-isolate
uh for ten days uh we will invigilate we
are invigilating it
and uh people who fail to obey uh the
the
quarantine can face fines mr speaker of
up to ten
thousand pounds kirsten mr speaker i
think everybody would agree that having
moved 170 countries to the amber list
absolute clarity is needed about the
circumstance in which people can travel
to an amber country
yesterday morning the environment
secretary said people could fly
to ambulance countries if they wanted to
visit family or friends
by the afternoon a government health
minister said nobody should travel
outside britain this year
and traveling is dangerous the prime
minister said that travel
to amber country should only be where
it's essential
by the evening the welsh secretary
suggested some people might think a
holiday is essential
the government's lost control of the
messaging so can the prime minister
answer a really
simple question that goes to the heart
of this if
it if he doesn't want people to travel
to ambulance
countries if that's his position he
doesn't want them to travel
to ambulance countries why has he made
it easier
for them to do so prime minister mr
speaker i think
after more than a year of this i think
right from german would understand that
what the public would like to see is
some effort to back up uh what the
government is saying
uh to to deliver uh clarity uh
of messages and on his point about legal
bans
as he knows we're trying to move away
from endlessly legislating
uh for everything and to rely on
guidance and
and asking people to do the right thing
and it is very very clear mr speaker
you should not be going to an amber list
country except for some extreme
circumstances
such as the the serious illness of a of
a family member you should not be going
to an ambulance country on holiday uh mr
speaker
imagine he wants to uh to take a holiday
but you should not be going to an
ambulance country
on holiday uh mr speaker and uh if you
if you do go to an ambulance country
then as i
say uh we will enforce the 10
day quarantine uh period and if you if
you break the rules
you face very substantial fines
mr speaker that completely swerves the
question the point was
if it's only in extreme circumstances
the prime minister's word
why make it easier to go if it's extreme
circumstances why make it easier to go
and mr speaker let's test it by looking
at the consequences
since the government loosened travel
restrictions 150 flights a day are going
to ambulance countries
and travel agents are reporting surges
in holiday bookings
to those countries prime minister this
isn't
just a coincidence it's because of the
messaging
so can the prime minister tell the house
how many people are now traveling to and
from britain
from ambulance countries every day
prime minister well i can tell the house
mr speaker is that there has been a 95
reduction in uh travel of any kind
uh to and from this country and that is
exactly what
uh you would expect in the circumstances
of this uh pandemic
uh there are 43 countries on the red
list and if you come back from those
countries you have to go immediately
into
uh into hotel quarantine and uh the
reason that we're able
uh to to move forward in the way that we
have is because as i have
told the house repeatedly we are
continuing with the fastest
vaccination rollout out
i think just about anywhere in uh in in
europe and
as of today 70 percent mr speaker of the
adults in this country
have been vaccinated and i think that is
a fantastic achievement and that is
enabling
us to make the progress that we are
fierce
that's and i don't know and the
suggestion that in the last
the suggestion that in the last few days
have been a 95 percent drop
off in trouble to ambulance country's
prime minister i don't think holds water
i'm trying to understand the logic of
the government's position
we know that new variants are the single
risk to unlock it
we know that the government doesn't
think people should travel to ambulance
countries save in extreme circumstances
but the government's made it easier to
do so the messaging is confused and
contradictory and as a result prime
minister
this week many people are now traveling
to ambulance countries
but the cup the government can't say how
many or when
mr speaker we're an island nation we
have the power to stop this
why doesn't the prime minister drop this
hopeless system get control of our
borders
and introduce a proper system that can
protect against the threat
of future variants of the virus
prime minister actually mr speaker i
think what would be helpful
i've set out the position about
ambulance countries i think uh very
clearly at least
at least twice wouldn't it be great mr
speaker to hear the right honourable
gentleman to backing it up for a change
uh getting you know using using what
authority he possesses
uh to convey the message uh to to the
rest of the
of the country actually mr speaker when
you look at the labour position
on on borders it's it's hopelessly
confused last night i think the shadow
home
secretary has said that they wanted to
cut the whole cut this country off from
the rest of the world mississippi
paul's all travel pause all travel even
though 75 percent of our medicines
and 50 percent of our food actually come
from abroad
uh mr speaker and it was only recently
that he was saying that quarantine
was a blunt instrument and he'd rather
see alternatives
here mr speaker the prime minister's
wrong again we've called for a blanket
hotel quarantine
for months i raised it here three times
at prime minister's questions
the government ignored it every time and
look where we are now talking about the
indian
variant mr speaker the prime minister's
former adviser
had this one right he said the
government's border policy was a joke
our borders have been wide out open
pretty well throughout the pandemic
there was no hotel quarantine system in
place until february this year but
that's not true
flights are still coming in from india
and even as the variant
is spreading the prime minister decides
now is the time to weaken the system
even more it's ridiculous
finally mr speaker i want to raise
i want to raise the appalling rise in
anti-semitism
in the last week on the attacks and the
violence
we've seen on saturday a rabbi in
chigwell was hospitalized
after being attacked outside his
synagogue many of us will have
seen the appalling incident in goldus
green and the community security trust
report a 500 percent rise in
anti-semitic incidents
since the break outbreak of violence in
gaza and israel
now i know the government is working on
this and both the
prime minister and i have condemned
these anti-semitic attacks
and violence but we will all know across
this house that jewish communities
remain
very anxious so what more does the prime
minister think
could be done to provide the extra
support and protection needed
to reassure jewish communities that this
really very difficult time by minister
well mr speaker i i i share his horror
at
the outbreak of anti-semitic incidents
and
uh the government has conveyed uh that
message
uh loud and clear to those who are
responsible for enforcing the law
against hate crime of that kind but
obviously we will continue to work and
uh to support the jewish community in
any way that we can particularly working
with community
safety trust who do an absolutely
outstanding job
uh in my view but also showing as a
country and as a society
that we will call this out at every
stage
mr speaker we will not let it take root
we will not allow it
to grow and fester and in welcoming uh
his remarks i i i may say i think it's
one of the
most important changes of attitude uh or
u-turns i should say that i've seen
uh from the labour party in recent times
and i'm i'm delighted
i'm delighted that he's taking he's
taking that attitude i'm delighted that
he's taking that attitude
now but i think what this what this
country uh what this country wants to
see mr speaker is a government
that gets on with delivering on the
people's priorities
making everybody safe and it might have
been a good thing mr speaker
if he had voted if he had voted and he's
got his party to vote
for tougher sentences for against
serious and violent
sexual offenders to say nothing of
people who commit
hate crimes i think in verna's this
house is very united and will
remain united and of course we do
support the cst
let's come to mary robinson thank you mr
speaker
my second dasher's edica job reinforced
my confidence
not only in normal life resuming but
also in the future of our life science
industry
in cheadle and across south manchester
and the cheshire life science corridor
investment in r d and innovation will
bring
high skilled well-paid jobs will the
prime minister join me in recognizing
and endorsing the work of our northern
universities
nhs trusts and life science sector who
together with the northern health
science alliance
our pilot piloting health tech
initiatives which will take us forward
from japs to jobs yes prime minister
yes mr speaker i thank my honourable
friend who is a great advocate for the
people
of cheval and as part of our plan to
move from jabs jabs jabs to jobs jobs
jobs i'm delighted to say that over a
billion pounds worth of
government-funded science
and innovation projects are currently
taking place across uh the north west
uh thanks uh largely or at least in part
to her advocacy
let's go to the leader of the snp in
blackfood here
thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
prime minister for these comments on the
valley murphy inquest mr speaker
as a member of scotland's crofton
community i understand
just how disastrous a brexit trade deal
with australia
as proposed by this tory government be
for scotland's
farming and crafting sectors if reports
of this
tory deal are true farmers will lose
their livelihoods
rural businesses will collapse and
ultimately families will be driven off
the land and let's be very clear
if that happens this uk tony government
will be solely responsible
so just for once prime minister give a
straight answer to these farming and
crafting families who are living with
this threat
can the prime minister categorically
rule out
that his government is prepared to sign
up to a trade deal
that will at any future point guarantee
tariff free access to australian land
and beef
yes or no minister mr speaker i know
that the right honourable about i'd like
to see
the shots of his croft uh by the way uh
the
the humble humble uh representative of
the crofting uh community
may i say that i i don't think that he
does justice
uh to uh to crofters to farmers across
the country
and of course in scotland as well mr
speaker because i think he grossly
underestimates their ability
uh to uh do great things with our free
trade deals
to export scottish beef around the world
mr speaker why doesn't he believe in
what the people of scotland can do mr
speaker why is he so frightened
of free trade i think there's a massive
opportunity for scotland and for the
whole of the uk
and he should seize it and be proud of
it
going back to him blackfoot in thank you
mr speaker that was quite chilling to
try and treat something as serious as
this
and the way that the government and the
prime minister has done is really
quite pathetic the fact that the prime
minister couldn't give a straight answer
will send a real chill across scotland's
farming communities
the uk government led the betrayal of
scottish fishing
and now the tories are planning to throw
our farmers and crafters under the
brexit bus this morning
martin kennedy president of the national
farmers union scotland
told itv that farmers will feel
seriously betrayed
by these proposals this deal would be
the final nail in the coffin for many
scottish crusters and farmers it will
end a way of life
that has endured for generations
generations prime minister
i know that many of the prime minister's
story colleagues
privately agree with me and want him to
pull back from this deal
so will the prime minister finally
listen think again
and ditch a deal that would send our
farmers down under
prime minister uh mr speaker uh i i i
really think well first of all he's
totally wrong about what he says about
the fisheries
uh because in fact there are massive
opportunities for fisheries for the
whole
of the uk as we take back control of our
territorial waters and that will be the
same for scotland and around the uk
and i think again he is he is he is
grossly uh underestimating the ability
of
the the people of this country the the
agricultural communities of this country
uh the farming industry to make the most
of free trade this is a country
this is a country that grew uh
successful and prosperous
on free trade on exporting around the
world our food exports are second to
none
mr speaker he should be proud of that he
should be celebrating that and all he
does mr speaker is call for us to put up
the drawbridge and go back
into the eu to be run by brussels that's
his manifesto and i i think the people
of this country have decisively rejected
it
joe gideon thank you mr speaker
north staff's ymca in my constituency
undertakes fantastic work
transforming the lives of young people
locally in the stoke-on-trent community
and i'm delighted that they have been
recognized for their work through the
queen's award for enterprise
there is no better example of leveling
up in action
and i would like to invite the prime
minister to join me in congratulating
all the staff volunteers and partners of
the ymca
in north staffordshire and i look
forward to showing him leveling up in
action
when he next visits stoke on trent the
new second home of the home office
prime minister i i thank
my honourable friend very much and she's
totally right and
it's part of our leveling up we're
absolutely determined to do this as fast
as we possibly can uh
thank you for uh my old friend's message
about it this morning uh we are we are
we are sending we are sending
not just back offices mr speaker uh but
uh
some of the most important departments
of state will be running will be run
uh from around our great cities and
towns in the whole of the uk and i
believe that will have a dramatic effect
on leveling up across the uk and i'm
thankful to her
for her question ed davey mr speaker
local planning reforms introduced by
liberal democrat ministers
have seen communities across england
vote for
new developments including new housing
new affordable housing new community
facilities
whilst also protecting the environment
of the countryside
so why is the prime minister so
determined to push through his planning
reforms
that will do nothing to solve the
country's
real housing crisis will allow
developers to ride roughshod
over local communities and will mean in
the words of his immediate predecessor
as prime ministers
the wrong homes being built in the wrong
places
mr speaker he's completely wrong and uh
he should look at the bill when it comes
forward
uh because uh we want to protect the
green belt we want to protect our
wonderful open spaces
uh this is a government that understands
the value of the uh of the countryside
and rural
uh rural britain but we also think that
young people
uh have been deprived for too long of
the ability to get onto the housing
ladder mr speaker and it's not just in
the southeast across the country
and that's why we're bringing forward
sensible reforms to like brownfield
sites to go ahead
andrew thank you very much uh mr speaker
two weeks ago
in giving the scottish conservatives
their highest ever number of votes in
the era of devolution
the scottish people decided that
scotland would remain at the heart
of this newly reinvigorated global
britain
so with that in mind with the prime
minister except my invitation to
stenhaven and my constituency
to come and plant one of 120 cherry
blossom trees
donated by the sakura cherry blossom
tree trust
to celebrate the deep and growing links
between our country and that other great
trading nation
japan prime minister uh yes mr speaker
and
uh i i think that uh such a gesture
would be the cherry on the cake
of the the free trade deal that we've
already done
paul williams thank you mr speaker in
2019 before visiting wales
the prime minister said i will always
back britain's great farmers
now it looks as if he's backing
australia's farmers instead
so will he uh today keep to his word
really bad quilt farmers and permanently
roll out started free access for
australian lamb and beef imports
i will i will back britain's farmers and
welsh farmers
uh in exporting uh their fantastic lamb
around the world
is it not a disgrace that not a single
morsel of welsh lamb
has so past the lips of the americans in
the last 20 years
or more mr speaker what about china mr
speaker has he no ambition
for the people of this country or for
the people of wales or for welsh farmers
i do this government does mr speaker
that's why we're getting on with our
agenda
thank you mr speaker does the prime
minister or preview when he dog
agree with me that a free port on
anglesey will create much needed skilled
jobs and investment
protect our precious welsh language and
culture and breathe fire into the
nostrils of the welsh dragon
and will the prime minister accept an
invitation on behalf of the people of
honest mourn to join me
on a tour of the island to include a pan
ad at the truck stop cafe
in hollyhead all right five minutes
mr speaker it says here that i mustn't
express a reference on the location of
freeports and i won't but she makes a uh
she makes a
standing case out as ever uh and uh she
and she is uh together with uh uh uh
our welsh colleagues she uh welsh
conservatives colleagues i believe she's
helping now
uh to apply the vix inhaler to the bund
up nostrils of the welsh dragon richard
thompson
thank you mr speaker despite the
appropriation which the prime minister
always seems to seek to keep upon the
scottish national party
at the scottish elections two weeks ago
the snp was returned to government
with twice the number of msps as their
nearest rivals in the scottish
conservatives
securing 48 of the votes 49
of the seats the proportional system and
with 51 percent of voters backing up
parties which support an independence
referendum in the current turn
so if the prime minister genuinely
believes that his criticisms of the
scottish government have any merit
whatsoever
why does he consider the scottish
national party did so well in those
elections
while his own party did so badly prime
minister
uh well mr speaker i i totally regret
reject what he's just
said i i noticed that actually the the
scottish national party did less well
uh than they did previously under alex
salmond uh in 2011. i hesitate to point
that out
to the honourable but that is the that
is the that is
the reality and i think the reason for
that is that the people of scotland
notwithstanding
uh the nationalist approach that he
takes the people of scotland
have been very disappointed uh by the
actual record of the scottish
government in fighting crime in
improving education
and in making scotland a great place uh
to live and to invest and that is the
failing
of which his government is being held to
account danny kruger
thank you mr speaker a large part of
salisbury plain falls in my constituency
of devises
and i therefore have the honour to
represent a lot of serving soldiers
and veterans and their families so my
right honourable friend will understand
that feelings are running high
in wiltshire about the treatment of
british army veterans of the
conflict in northern ireland can he
assure me that legislation will be
brought forward in this session
to protect veterans from further
prosecutions or investigations unless
compelling new evidence is brought
forward
prime minister mr speaker the house will
have understood from my
opening apology how difficult how
complex uh and how fraught these issues
are but we are committed to introduce
legislation
uh in this session uh to address the
legacy of the troubles in
in northern ireland and to introducing a
a fair package
uh for veterans as well and to protect
them as
i've said many times before from unfair
vexatious
litigation where no new evidence has
been brought forward general judge
thank you mr speaker there were no new
measures in the queen's speech to tackle
youth unemployment there are over 500
000 unemployed young people
in this country at the government's
flagship youth unemployment scheme is
nowhere near
efficient sufficient only helping around
one in 25
young people i and my honorable friend
for blind gwent have already requested a
meeting with a minister to discuss local
concerns
from training providers and local
businesses so could i ask the prime
minister what exactly he's going to do
to address this
and to safeguard the future of a
generation of young people in this
country
we're putting two but very quickly mr
speaker would be 2 billion pounds into
the kickstart
program for 18 to 24 year olds uh and uh
and investing massively in the restart
program for those who've been uh
longer out of work but uh can i i can
also tell them the businesses i talk to
are currently facing shortages
of workers in many many sectors and we
will work flat out
to ensure that we get uh those who want
jobs uh to those
uh who need uh workers as well thank you
mr speaker can i thank the prime
minister for the support he's already
shown for
coming forward with an offshore
transmission grid which he knows will
help us both to
export our surplus offshore wind into
the continent and reduce the
infrastructure associated with
new wind farm capacity so it's very
important to our communities but there's
a question
over timing so given that he's already
set out a very ambitious and clear
timetable to increasing offshore wind
generation will he now come out with an
equally ambitious timetable for
delivering an offshore grid
prime minister my honourable friend is
spot on in what he says about
the need for an offshore grid uh as well
as the
building though the the fantastic uh
windmills it's vital that we bring the
the energy onshore uh in a way that is
uh uh as uh has minimal disruption
uh for local uh communities and it
enables us to to maximize efficiency
oh thank you mr speaker what does the
prime minister think
when he hears jenny mcgee the nurse who
saved his life
say of nhs staff we're not getting the
respect
and now pay that we deserve i'm just
sick of it
so i've handed in my resignation surely
even he must pause and think
what can be learned from the mistakes of
the past year
what jenny calls the indecisiveness and
mixed messages
of his government and will he think
again about giving nurses more than an
insulting
one percent pay rise
uh mr speaker i think the whole house
acknowledges our
collective debt to the nurses of the nhs
and i certainly acknowledge my own
huge personal debt and that's why of all
the professions
uh in this country mr speaker in very
very tough times
we have asked the public sector pay
review board to look at
uh an increase in pay for nurses but in
the meantime we have increased starting
salary for nurses by 12.8 percent we
have put in
uh the bursary worth five thousand
pounds we've restored that mr speaker
as well as three thousand pounds for
extra help but above all mr speaker
to all nurses and i know what a tough
year they have had i know how hard it
has been
on the front line coping with this
pandemic we have done what i think is
the most important thing of all
and that is to recruit many more nurses
there are now about 11 000
more nurses in the nhs today than there
were
this time last year and there are 60 000
more mr speaker
in training and we are on target to
reach our target
of 50 000 more nurses in the nhs so
james davis
following on that theme mr speaker
patients in england have unfettered
access to specialist hospital care
anywhere in england including within
world
leading centres of excellence but my
constituents in north wales have no such
automatic choice
with access dependent on restrictive
contracts or individual funding requests
so will my right honourable friend do
all he can to ensure that healthcare
features prominently within the uk
leveling up agenda
prime minister yes i i thank my uh
honourable friend for
uh for his point and he he knows a great
deal about
uh the subject uh we've worked very hard
with the
uh with the welsh government throughout
the pandemic uh supporting
uh them with eight point six billion
pounds of individual additional funding
through the book through the barnet
formula
uh but clearly we need to learn the
lessons together as we as we bounce
forward from this pandemic
just in matters yeah thank you mr
speaker it's now 664 days since the
prime minister said he had a plan for
social care
but the department for health and social
care are advertising at the moment for
social care policy advices too and i
quote
develop proposals for reform why do that
if there is a plan already
every day more people lose their life
savings to page huge social
care costs and we can't even get a
straight answer as to whether the
government have a plan
to fix social care never mind find out
what it actually is
so just tell us prime minister do you
have a plan yes or no
uh mr speaker yes is the answer but i
mean the the labour party
the labour party jumped it jumped it in
1999 this is so this is something that
for
decades uh politicians have failed to
address
1999 labor failed to
uh address the plan they they had a year
13 years in government mr speaker
i think it was 13 13 unlucky years for
this country
they didn't do it and they didn't do it
and this government is going to tackle
it
this government is going to is going to
finally going to address the issue of
social care and if they want to support
it
with their customary with their
customary doubting
doubting resolve mr speaker if they want
to support it without wibble wobbling
from one week to the next in whatever
their policy is uh they're not
without changing like willow veins which
is what they normally
if they want to support it if they want
to back it then i'm all ears mr speaker
thank you mr speaker throughout this
week businesses across burmese and
padium have reopened their doors
to customers inside from usher and molly
rigby's
to bellissimo and real cinema would the
prime minister join with me and wishing
them all the best of luck
as they get back on the feet and does he
also agree with me that if we're to
support local businesses
in the long term we need to create the
environment and the opportunities they
need
to succeed and that includes schemes
like the leveling up fund
and the lifetime skills guaranteed
yes mr speaker that's why we're uh we're
investing
for instance uh 3.6 million pounds from
the getting building fund for the
development of
uh of pioneer place uh burnley will also
benefit from our our high streets task
force but what did
what uh berlin and towns uh across the
country need more than anything else is
passionate leadership
uh such as my honorable friend shows in
championing uh
their localities and getting the right
investment in
final question david lynch thank you mr
speaker the prime minister will be aware
of
lattice's proposal to close the
mcveigh's factory in glasgow's east end
putting at risk
up to 470 local jobs so while the prime
minister joined with me in engaging with
plato's global ceo
salman and call upon him to rethink
these plans which would definitely
unleash
economic armageddon on a very very very
fragile part of the local economy yeah
yeah
prime minister yes i'm i think uh
mcbiddies have been a proud part of the
scottish economy
uh since uh 1800 and i i know that uh
people at the of the toll cross uh
factory their relatives will be very
concerned about
uh what's happening i thank him uh for
raising it i know that conversations are
uh are now going on uh to see what we
can uh do with i think it's the turkish
company
uh that now owns um vities uh
and i know my our honourable friend the
secretary of state for scotland is
uh is meeting honourable uh member to
discuss the situation
i know suspending the house for three
minutes to enable necessary arrangements
the next business
order and next business
is going to be a statement on the
situation in the middle east
particularly gaza
uh from james cleveland reply to an
urgent question we will bring you
that uh with me is uh beth rigby here
to look through all that incidentally i
was wondering what the prime minister is
wearing in his lapel that is the badge
uh for uh dementia awareness week
sponsored by the alzheimer's society
beth what were your main points from
that well look the question
look the main point was the new piece of
information that the prime minister gave
us about this data the wait and see
approach on whether or not the unlocking
on june the 21st can go ahead
as planned or whether the indian variant
has thrown it all off course you said in
the chamber
when quizzed by sarkia on the matter of
uh foreign travel we have increasing
confidence that vaccines
are effective against all variants
including
the indian variant so early data the
prime minister
seemingly cautiously optimistic there
there will be a press conference with
matt hancock the health secretary
uh this afternoon is
is a good enough insurance to contain
the indian variance exactly and why does
that matter well
because as you know on the tests one of
them is increased hospitalizations
that's what mark harper
was talking about the conservative mp
before pmqs and it's about whether or
not
in that race between the virus and the
vaccine
are enough people vaccinated or is the
vaccine effective enough that it doesn't
completely
throw the plan into disarray and lead to
increased hospitalizations now of course
there's a risk of transmissibility
that there are then new mutations of the
virus so then does the
vaccine become less effective but that
was i would read as
pretty positive from the prime minister
and there was some clarification
on what an ambassador means as far as
travel
exactly so that was kirsten's point
which is this mixed messaging is very
confusing
you're putting these countries on the
ambulance over 100
planes are going out to all these
destinations what on earth are you doing
and the prime minister there very clear
saying
the messaging is you should not be going
to an ambulance country
on holiday or for anything other than
extreme
circumstances so trying to reiterate
there to people
that there are a dozen countries on the
green list which are safe to travel to
a lot of them i'm not sure you can even
get to would want to
i mean the falkland islands is quite a
long way to go for a holiday isn't it
although
beautiful down there actually um but
those are hundreds
those 173 countries on the ambulance
he's saying they're on the ambulance but
please don't go
people are still going but that was the
message as often
quite a lot of animus between the prime
minister and the snp
what's all that about today yeah so this
is the issue that's bubbling up now on
an on a free trade deal between
australia
and the uk uh ian blackford the snp
westminster leader there
raising the issue that free trade and
tariff-free meat products lamb and beef
coming in from
australia to the uk markets could kill
off
businesses of crofters in scotland
and the prime minister pretty dismissive
of that there if you wanted a hint of
where boris johnson is leading in the
battle
within government between his trade
secretary liz trust and
and others in his cabinet george eustis
who looks after farmers
about where the prime minister is on
free trade he gave a pretty clear answer
there saying
free trade deals is good for the country
and will bring massive opportunities
there is a debate within government
about free trade access
for all the reasons uh that ian
blackford was pointing out there which
some country uh some businesses were
worried that it will put them out of
business
i'd like to cut them beth thank you and
go now to uh the urgent question on the
israel palestine
ceasefire in israel and gaza i know call
minister james cleveland
thank you mr speaker since i was last at
the dispatch box
on the 13th of may we have sadly seen
further violence and more civilian
deaths i'm sure the house will join me
in offering condolences to all the
families
of those civilians who have been killed
or injured across israel
and the occupied palestinian territories
mr speaker with your
permission i will set out to the house
the work the government is doing
along with others to bring about a
peaceful resolution
we are urging the parties to work with
mediators towards
an immediate ceasefire to prevent
further loss of life
and a worsening humanitarian situation
we are supporting united nations
egyptian and qatari efforts to that end
and we work
closely with the united states we're
also prioritizing our own
diplomatic efforts through both
bilateral and multilateral channels
the foreign secretary and i with the
support of our diplomats on the ground
have been working to progress the
conditions needed
for an immediate ceasefire the foreign
secretary has spoken in recent days with
the
israeli foreign minister and the
palestinian prime minister
where he reinforced our clear message of
de-escalation and our desire to work
together to end the violence
i delivered similar messages to the
ambassador to the israeli ambassador
and the palestinian head mission in
london we've also engaged regional
partners at ministerial level
the foreign secretary spoke with the
foreign minister of jordan on the 17th
of may
and i spoke just this morning with a
number of ambassadors from arab states
to reiterate the need for immediate
ceasefire and underlined our shared
goals of a peaceful two-state solution
we are playing a leadership role in the
united nations security council
where we are calling for measures by all
sides to reduce further violence
we will participate in the emergency un
general assembly
session later this week the uk
unequivocally condemns the firing of
rockets at jerusalem and other locations
within
israel we strongly condemn these acts of
terrorism by hamas and other terrorist
groups
who must permanently end their
incitement and rocket fire against
israel
there is no justification for the
targeting of civilians
israel has a legitimate right to
self-defense and to defend its citizens
from attack
in doing so it is right it is vital
that all actions are proportionate in
line with international humanitarian law
and make every effort to avoid civilian
casualties
we are aware of the uh of medical
institutions
a number of schools and many homes in
gaza that have been destroyed or
seriously damaged
and we are concerned that buildings
housing media
and humanitarian organizations such as
qatar red
crescent have been destroyed we call on
israel to adhere
to the principles of necessity and
proportionality
when defending its legitimate security
interests we are
also concerned by reports that hamas
is once again using civilian
infrastructure and populations
as a cover for its military operations
humanitarian access is essential we urge
all parties to allow the unimpeded entry
of vital humanitarian supplies hamas and
other terrorist groups must
cease their mortar attacks on these
crossings
we use all parties to work together to
reduce tensions in the west bank
including east jerusalem
the uk is clear that historic status quo
in jerusalem
must be respected violence against
peaceful worshipers
of any faith is unacceptable
mr speaker the uk position on evictions
demolitions and settlements is clear and
long-standing
we oppose these activities we urge the
government of
israel to cease its policies related to
settlement expansion immediately
and instead work towards a two-state
solution mr speaker the uk will continue
our intensive diplomatic efforts in the
region
focused on securing a ceasefire and
creating the conditions
for a sustainable peace can just remind
people that we do offset times we're
going to try and stick to
when death thank you mr speaker
it is of enormous concern to everyone in
the house
about in this conflict between hamas and
israel
there have been nearly 300 people killed
including 65 children this is truly
appalling
and we condemn the rocket attacks by
hamas and the israeli airstrikes which
have killed
so many innocent people and severely
damaged schools
and medical facilities i listened
carefully to what the minister had to
say
regarding the government's position and
his statement in favor of
an immediate cease fire we have heard
of the last few hours but the french and
jordanian governments are making real
efforts to bring about a u.n resolution
which will help secure an immediate
ceasefire we have heard
but there have been discussions with the
egyptians and the germans
the name of the united kingdom
government has not been mentioned
and i would ask the minister if he would
care to elaborate upon what
representations
he's recently made to secure that
objective of
an immediate ceasefire could i also
press the minister
on what efforts his government is making
to provide humanitarian support for
people of gaza
and i would also urge the government to
do everything it can
to restart a meaningful peace process as
a matter of urgency
if further configurations are to be
prevented
we need a process which will uphold
international law
end the illegal occupation of the
palestinian territories
and create a viable palestinian state
alongside a secure
israel minister
mr speaker i thank the honourable
gentleman for the recognition he has
given as to the diplomatic work that the
uk government has put in i can assure
him
that we remain fully committed to an
immediate ceasefire and we're working to
that end
as i say the uh the foreign secretary
spoke with his jordanian
opposite number um just a few days ago
and i spoke to ambassadors from the
region
just this morning uh some of the
diplomatic efforts are quite rightly
done
uh very visibly through institutions
such as the united nations
son some are i'm sure he'll understand
why
done perhaps more discreetly and quietly
the international community is pulling
together
in both in the region in europe and in
the united states to try and bring about
a meaningful ceasefire and work towards
what can only
be the uh the right way of bringing a
um permanent piece to the region which
is through
negotiated political means
israel has the right to defend its
citizens from terrorist attack
and i welcome the minister's strong
confirmation of that
this morning will he go further though
uh and send a message about terrorism by
prescribing the whole of hamas and also
the irgc that are making possible these
horrific
rocket attacks minister
i thank my right honourable friend for
the uh for the points that
she has made she will know the military
wing of hamas is internationally
recognized as a terrorist organization
and the entirety of hamas is on a no
contact
we have a no contact policy from the uk
government
we enjoy a good working relationship
with the leadership of the palestinian
authority
solutions to this will be done need to
be must be done
through negotiated political means
rather than through military means
she will also understand that we do not
speculate on future prescriptions
we now go to smp spokesperson chris law
chris
mr speaker we are witnessing the second
week of horrific violence in israel and
palestine
it's reported that 10 have been killed
by hamas and over 200 have been killed
by israelis airstrikes including 65
children
the snp applause all indiscriminate
violence against civilians
so firstly what further steps can the uk
government take in demanding an
immediate ceasefire
mr speaker i'm incredibly proud that
last month my city of dundee voted to
recognize palestine
as a nation-state so secondly will the
uk government today commit to
recognizing palestine as an equal
and independent nation-state the u.n
secretary general has accused israeli
government of acting contrary to their
obligations under human rights law
indeed amnesty international have
highlighted potential war crimes
by both israel and hamas so thirdly
what pressures is the uk government
bringing to investigate these shocking
bridges
lastly mr speaker uk arms export
licenses to israel have increased by
over 1 000
in the last two years this is not
neutrality
therefore finally will the uk government
immediately suspend these exports
until they are thoroughly examined
uh mr speaker uh i i
i would urge the honorable gentleman
whom i have a huge amount of respect
not to equate the legitimate government
of israel with a
terrorist organization the military wing
of
hamas as i have said at the dispatch box
a number of times
israel has a right to self-defense but
we've also made it clear that we expect
at all times for them to do so in
accordance with international
humanitarian
law and make every effort to minimise
civilian
casualties but ultimately the best way
of minimizing civilian
civilian casualties is to bring this
conflict to a conclusion
that is why we are working both with
palestinian leadership
the government of israel and our
international partners both in the
region and further afield
to bring a timely end to this conflict
work towards a more permanent ceasefire
and ultimately to a peaceful two-state
solution
let's go to robert halford robert
thank you mr speaker reports indicate
that at least 500 hamas rockets
one in seven of the total number fired
have exploded within gaza and the
palestinian ngo
has confirmed that eight palestinians
were killed last week by a rocket that
fell short does my rightful friend agree
with me that hamas rocket fire doesn't
just threaten israelis it also causes
great harm to
ordinary gazans and must be condemned in
the strongest possible terms
would he also acknowledge that far from
being able to negotiate with the
democratic palestinian government
israel is facing existential threats
from hamas and hezbollah
extreme islamist terrorist organizations
funded and backed by iran
and that there should be no moral
equivalence between democratic israel
and the terrorism of hamas and hezbollah
mr speaker the uk enjoys good relations
both with the
government of israel and the palestinian
authority
and i would urge uh all members of the
house and further afield to recognize
that hamas which is the military wing of
which is recognized as a terrorist
organization
is no friend of the palestinian people
we will
work with the leadership of both the
palestinians
and the israelis alongside our friends
and partners internationally
to work for peace because ultimately
nobody wants to see continued images of
uh of fatalities of either palestinians
or israelis
let's go to leila moran leila
speaker last week i read the names of
four
of the then 14 palestinian children and
one israeli child who had died
and a week on the number of palestinian
children dead
is now 63 in gaza alone
my heart was broken before it's
shattered now
we need a ceasefire and the uk
shouldn't have left it to france to be
the main sponsor of a un resolution
calling for it this government is
shirking its historic responsibility and
it is time to step
up so today i wear my kefir
in recognition that if we want lasting
peace we cannot go back to how it was
before
the police brutality the demolitions and
the oppression
we need a peace process that isn't
doomed before it begins
so if this government is committed to a
lasting peace
then why doesn't it recognize the state
of palestine
mr speaker i recognise the honourable
lady's passion for the palestinian
people and her own background uh and i
completely understand how
painful it is for her in particular but
for all of us seeing
images of those who have lost their
lives i can assure her
that we are working with international
partners both at the united nations
and more broadly to bring about peace
when i last stood at the dispatch box in
response to her urgent question
i made the case i made the point then
that the uk was pushing towards a
cessation of
violence and uh cease-fire and we we
are absolutely committed to a meaningful
two-state
solution mr speaker the issue of
palestinian recognition is one that
is uh rightly to be debated in this
house but at this point
our focus is relentlessly on bringing
about an immediate end to the conflict
so that we can work in good time to a
negotiated political solution
and a two-state solution for the benefit
of both the israeli and the palestinian
peoples
steve ducklin thank you mr speaker i
welcome my right honorable friend
statement and the commitment to a
two-state solution
can my right honorable friend update the
house as to what extent we are using our
presidency of the g7
to help to broker an international
consensus
for a ceasefire
uh i i i thank the honourable lady for
her
for her question uh we we are using all
of our diplomatic contacts contacts
and our diplomatic leverage
understandably the united nations is
the predominant multilateral body
through which we are working but as i
say i spoke to
a meeting of the arab ambassadors just
this morning
we are ambivalent as to which
organization helps bring about peace and
we'll work with whomever
wherever uh we feel able to apply
um positivity but i can assure her that
we will we will
leave no stone unturned in our efforts
to bring about
an end to this conflict dr rupa huck the
sad aftermath of a tragedy where
children pulled from the rubble are
considered
lucky amongst a three-figure death toll
is he said it himself
newly displaced people from their homes
double refugees
destroyed schools hospitals cultural
centers
all at a time when we're cutting our aid
contribution internationally
would he agree with his two recent
predecessors
alastair burke and alan duncan that
although he stated it again uk
government policy
is against illegal settlements and for a
two-state solution
our long-standing lack of proactivity
sometimes looks like
we don't really mean this and the only
real victory of all this is netanyahu
until recently a caretaker leader of an
inconclusive elect
election that's now he's now well
cemented himself
um mr speaker the uh the outcome of
democratic elections in the state of
israel is
uh is for the israeli people we will
continue to work
with the governments that the israeli
people
elect but it does strike me that that is
a an important but fundamentally
different issue
to the one that is the subject of the
urgent question today we will work
with international partners with the
israelis with the palestinians
to bring peace to the region both in
terms of
this specific conflict which we seek to
resolve
as quickly as possible and ultimately
for
a sustainable prosperous two-state
solution
that remains the uk government's policy
thank you mr speaker iran's role in this
conflict is just one more example
of uh iranian efforts to undermine peace
and stability throughout the middle east
via its proxy terror group allies
given that it was exactly this kind of
behavior that many
warned was a blind spot in the jcpoa
agreement what assurances can my
wrapable friend give today that the
current discussions around
resuscitating that agreement won't just
repeat that mistake
all over again and give a free pass to
iran to continue rearming
its hamas allies
mr speaker my right honourable friend
makes an incredibly important
point and we recognize that in our
uh in our desire to prevent iran from
acquiring nuclear weapon
we cannot be blind to their broader
regional
destabilizing activity that will remain
one of the uk's priorities
um it is something which is regularly
raised with me by
my interlocutors in the region and i can
assure him
that will be at the forefront of our
minds throughout the forthcoming
negotiations
richard thank you mr speaker how many
more palestinian children have to be
killed
how many more palestinian homes have to
be reduced
to rubble how many more palestinian
schools
and hospitals have to be bombed before
the british government takes the action
necessary to finally force the israeli
government
to stop its war on the palestinian
people
surely now is the time for all
uk weapon sales to israel
to be stopped surely now is the time
for sanctions on the israeli government
for its repeated
violations of international law and
surely now is the time
this house voted for it back in 2014
to recognize the state of palestine
because palestine has the right to exist
mr speaker i would remind the honorable
gentleman of the sequencing
of the events that have unfolded in
gaza and israel israel's actions were in
response
to indiscriminate rocket attacks from an
internationally recognised terrorist
organization israel has the right to
self-defense we have urged them at
every step to do so proportionately and
and make every step that they are able
to to minimize
civilian casualties i am sure like him
i am horrified when uh sorry i'm sure
like me he is horrified
when we see images of fatalities whether
they be
israeli or palestinians and that is why
whilst the issue of recognition is an
important one it is not for now
now it's about bringing this conflict to
an end
thank you mr speaker could i welcome the
minister statement here today but given
our history
and our legacy there could i ask britain
leans into this more
uh we call for a ceasefire let's ask the
united states to join us there as well
it's difficult to see
how any tactical or strategic advantage
could be gained from either side
continuing this conflict
but once we get to that ceasefire of
course those old
legacy challenges will remain and israel
will require
a partner to work with my concern is
that palestinian elections have not
taken place for about 16 years
and hamas is now supported by
the iranians and has no interest in
either working with fatah in the west
bank
let alone the israelis so would my right
on a friend agree that perhaps
the neighboring muslim countries
particularly those who just signed the
abraham accords
could be invited to help encourage
palestinians to hold fresh elections
so we get more representative voices for
which israel
can then work with
thank you mr speaker he makes an
incredibly important point the uk has
been fully supportive
of elections for the palestinian
authority which are now
well overdue we have seen on numerous
occasions the palestinian authority
working and coordinating with the
government of israel and we are always
supportive
when that is the case the actions taken
by hamas
are not to the benefit of the
palestinian people
the solution to the conflict both in the
short term and
ultimately will be through a negotiated
political solution
and i would urge the palestinian people
to choose leadership
who are respected on the international
stage and are able to negotiate with
international partners
because the minister is very very
balanced response to the questions have
been put
the minister knows that hamas is trying
to make the palestinian authority
and mahmoud abbas redundant to make him
appear relevant to present themselves as
the ultimate defenders of jerusalem
and i'll accept our own history in this
country
proves a following of doing business
with terrorists will the minister take
the opportunity today to tell hummus
that the british government will never
do business
with terrorists mr speaker he makes the
point that the military wing for mass is
recognized as a terrorist
organization and ultimately the future
of the palestinian people lies
uh should lie in the hands of people who
are able to negotiate
on the international stage and hamas is
not
in a position to credibly do that
thank you mr speaker i welcome the prime
minister's call for both sides to step
back from the brink and show
restraint does my right honourable
friend agree that continued escalation
in the region will only lead to further
violence and more deaths
and that both sides need to urgently
down their arms
mr speaker my honourable friend mates
absolutely
the right point um the images that we've
seen of fatalities and injuries are
heartbreaking of both israelis and
palestinians
we continue to work with international
partners to
work to peace and an ultimate
sustainable
two-state solution let's go to jeremy
corbyn
jeremy thank you mr speaker
the images of death destruction and loss
of life
all over the region are horrific the
targeted bombing that has taken place
on buildings in gaza the tanks on the
west bank
and the destruction of educational and
health facilities
is absolutely appalling could the
minister explain
exactly what is the nature of britain's
military relationship with israel
what is the nature of that cooperation
with israel
and can he tell the house if any
weapons sold by britain or munitions
sold by britain
to israel have been used to bomb places
in gaza or if any drone equipment that
is supplied by britain or bought by
britain
has been used as a surveillance method
on either the west bank or gaza
that has been followed up by destruction
of civilian life
and the death of many people including
the tragedy of the death
of whole families and children i think
our public need to know
exactly what the nature of this military
relationship is
with israel and of course he quite
rightly says
the occupied territories which are
occupied by israel
are the places that suffer as a result
of this bombardment
minister uh mr speaker the uk
has a robust
arms export licensing regime and all
export licenses
are assessed in accordance with it i can
assure
him that the uk takes its arms export
responsibilities
very seriously and i would also remind
him that
israel is responding to rockets fired at
it
from an organization closely associated
with
iran and we would urge all nations to
take
their arms export responsibilities as
seriously as the uk does
well james cleverly there uh uh
answering an urgent question on the
situation
on gaza unequivocally condemning the
violence between israel
and the palestinians in that part of the
world called on israel to adhere to
international regulations uh stop
settlement expansion and take part in a
ceasefire also called on hamas to cease
its attacks uh he points out that
violence against any religion is not
acceptable at all and is very keen to
encourage still
a two-state solution well let's go live
to our correspondent alex rossi who's in
jerusalem
anything particularly new from mr
cleverly there alex
well i think the uh the reaction from
the british government was fairly
predictable but i don't think any of
those calls for an immediate ceasefire
are going to be heard here the violence
continues
uh all the time it may have dropped a
little bit in intensity but rockets are
still being
fired from civilian areas in gaza into
civilian areas
in israel the israeli air force is also
attacking what it claims are hamas
targets inside the gaza strip it claims
it's been targeting
what it's called the metro